[Applause]
40 good afternoon good afternoon
afternoon everybody
afternoon this this morning I I went to
Bucky and Palace and I am forming a new
government and on Monday MPs will arrive
at Westminster to form a new Parliament
and I'm proud to say that members of our
new one nation government a People's
Government will set out from
constituencies that have never returned
a Conservative MP for 100 years and yes
they will have an overwhelming mandate
from this election to get brexit done
and we will honor that mandate by
January the 31st and so in this moment
of national resolution I want to speak
directly to those who made it possible
and to all those who voted for us for
the first time and those whose pencils
may have wavered over the ballot and who
heard the voices of their parents and
their grandparents whispering anxiously
in their ears I say thank you for the
trust you have placed in us and in me
and we will work round the clock to
repay your trust and to deliver on your
priorities with a parliament that works
for you and then I want to speak also to
those who did not vote for us or for me
and who wanted and perhaps still want to
remain in the EU and I want you to know
that we in this one nation Conservative
government will never ignore your good
and positive feelings of warmth and
sympathy towards the other nations of
Europe because now is the moment
precisely as we leave the EU to let
those natural feelings find renewed
expression in building a new partnership
which is one of the great projects for
next year and as we work together with
the EU as friends and sovereign equals
in tackling climate change and terrorism
in building academic and scientific
cooperate
redoubling our trading relationship i
frankly urge everyone on either side of
what are after three years three and a
half years after all an increasingly
arid argument I urge everyone to find
closure and to let the healing begin
because I believe in fact I know because
I've heard it loud and clear from every
corner of the country that the
overwhelming priority of the British
people now is that we should focus above
all on the NHS that simple and beautiful
idea that represents the best of our
country with the biggest ever cash boost
fifty thousand more nurses forty new
hospitals as well as providing better
schools safer streets and in the next
few weeks and months we will be bringing
for proposals to transform this country
with better infrastructure better
education better technology and if you
ask yourselves what is this new
government going to do what are you
going to do with the extraordinary
majority I will tell you that is what we
are going to do we are going to unite
and level up unite and level up ringing
together the whole of this incredible
United Kingdom England Scotland Wales
Northern Ireland together taking us
forward unleashing the potential of the
whole country delivering opportunity
across the entire nation and since I
know that after five weeks frankly
electioneering this country deserves a
break from wrangling a break from
politics and a permanent break from
talking about brexit I want everyone to
go about their Christmas preparations
happy and secure in the knowledge that
here in this people's government the
work is now being stepped up to make
2020 year of prosperity and growth and
hope and to deliver a parliament that
works for the people thank you all very
much and happy Christmas thank you